[Music]
hey everybody what's going on hopefully
you guys had a good uh holiday yesterday
i mean at least if you're in the united
states it's not a holiday anywhere else
i know that but yeah uh so yeah last
night just like we threatened or just
like we said we would
watch the [ __ ] ambulance
3d also known as amityville 3 the demon
yeah
okay
i kept seeing this uh
video at the video rental store when i
was when i was a kid i'd say a kid i was
probably i was probably in my 20s
but i would have seen it in my teens too
83 of this camera 83 so i've seen it in
my teens also i remember that cover art
going man that looks terrible the cover
art is kind of shitty it had like a
[ __ ] green hand and lightning bolts
and an eye or something it just looked
like something out of them terror vision
or some cheesy [ __ ] look like
something off of a comedy
and i was going 3d that's always a bad
side you know i mean amityville [ __ ]
you know
so i never rented it
i watched it last night it started it
was good until the movie kept rolling
and i was going this is cooking kind of
going sideways
it got boring in a couple spots and then
in the end i realized man they kind of
remade the entity in a way
a tad i mean the end of this isn't quite
as
bad [ __ ] insane as the end of the entity
is it's like
there are no frozen ghosts of well not
well now there was some [ __ ] froze there
was some kind of frozen go okay i take
that back i take that back it's not a
it's not
it's not a bad movie it's it's actually
pretty well made for its time it had
good acting kinda and good actors in it
they were kind of numb
they weren't [ __ ] a list or anything
of course but i recognized a lot of
people that were in it
and um
i don't know it just needed about 20 or
30 minutes cut out of it i think it kind
of had it was kind of ponderous but
jenny liked it because it they're trying
to do slow burn and then end it like an
action movie like like like it's like
the entity
yeah and it didn't quite work because i
think that i think this [ __ ] at the
beginning and it could be just because
fourth row down said is meg ryan in this
one yes
uh i believe this is meg ryan's first
her first debut like screen appearance a
young meg very young meg ryan yeah she's
playing like the a friend of like the
teenage daughter of the main couple
she's probably late teens early 20s yeah
she's actually really good in this you
can actually tell like you you know
she's very charismatic yeah so you can
tell but pretty much everybody in this
just like the second one pretty much
everybody in this is familiar yeah uh
you know ev it's got like it's not a b
brand movie no no no it's uh it's like
something that came out of a studio
yeah it was um i think it was orion
orion okay and this was actually dino de
laurentiis produced it
uh again they had the lutz family were
suing because they were like we wanted
you to make a movie about us god damn it
even though they didn't even have
anything to do with the emergency so
this one um
is kind of like
it's sort of based on again like the
paranormal angle but it's based a little
bit on i think the guy's name is stephen
kaplan who was like uh
uh what was he like a journalist or
paranormal investigator or something
like that where he was trying to prove
that the lutz family that they were
hoaxing
uh so he actually kind of did an
investigation at the house so it's sort
of like loosely based a little bit on
that i don't think it's based on a book
or anything and this was actually like
the last amityville movie that
played in the theaters like there was a
been a [ __ ] on well up until they made
the remake and whatever that was 2005
2006 i don't remember with uh ryan
reynolds i think was in that wasn't he
that wasn't that actually wasn't bad but
um yeah so that was the last one like
there have been a bajillion like
amityville movies but they all
went direct to video and the thing about
it is because
amityville but it wasn't i mean it was
loosely based on a true story and you
can't really copyright it because it's
like the name of a town or anything like
that so
there have been because i was watching
this other review earlier there have
been like all of these cheap knockouts
that are just like amityville whatever
like amityville and we build a shark
amityville shark damn evil clown
you know whatever porn star
there there is
there is an amityville vibrator okay a
movie yeah uh that that is apparently
right in there
that is apparently a real thing that
doesn't exist man
doesn't care about your [ __ ] gender
either just doesn't care
it's a bisexual vibrator it's a watch
out
it's just like compared to normal
i can't believe i'm talking crazy like
this i'm not even feeling that good but
yeah maybe being sick tomorrow if i'm
sick i'm gonna [ __ ] do the show
anyway i'm gonna get drunk sick
usually if i'm sick it kind of helps me
well it depends on what kind of sick it
is if i have a cold then usually if i
drink some i kind of feel a little bit
better i feel a little bit like
lightheaded and dizzy and my sinuses are
kind of [ __ ] up
so uh one of my other personalities is
talking the venom one is talking
well when when is that one not talking i
kind of feel like true the other one's
kind of like mr hyde
so it's yeah it's basically a choice to
be venom and mr hyde
you don't have a doctor you don't have a
dr jekyll personality
they're just all villains yeah
said isn't there an amityville movie
where it's in a lamp yes yeah it sucked
uh we saw it actually we didn't see it
well i'm not gonna say we didn't see it
on purpose we saw it because they did a
rifftrax live yeah of it inside the
theater rifftrack yeah so we saw that so
we thought it saw it in the theater and
it's yeah it's terrible but you want to
see that movie you see the rift tracks i
mean it's much better any bad movie is
always going to be improved by the
addition of roof tracks because
otherwise it's going to be like a real
chore to sit through that has nothing to
do with andyville i think it's just
called amityville it's about time
see i thought it was the fourth one but
i don't think it is because i think
amityville four was called something
else i don't know i lost track with this
one but the thing about amityville 3d
i think i said this first came out in
the theaters in 1983 and i think i saw
it on cable must have been like a year
later i didn't see it in the theater i
don't think although it's possible that
i might have how old was i eleven
four down loves the last one
i love lamp yep
well well i liked the we liked the the
rifftrax version i mean like yeah like i
said i don't think i could have sat
through that without those people
[ __ ] ragging on it probably not
although the thing about it is like if
i'm watching a [ __ ] movie that doesn't
have the riptrax treatment then i will
just provide my own commentary yeah so
you know so i can do that too unless
it's really really boring
in which case i just get like
demoralized and turn it off but yeah so
i so i think i saw this on cable because
i feel like this was on cable all the
[ __ ] time
because
i'm like watching i was like oh i
remember some [ __ ] about this
and when i was watching it again last
night like so much of it was like coming
back i said jesus i must have seen this
when i was 12 13 years old probably like
a hundred times because i remembered
like so much [ __ ] like you know i'd
forgotten it over the years but when i
was watching it again
so yeah i found out okay so the director
of this
because i i saw his name richard
fleischer and i was like oh that's
familiar i know that guy so i looked
that guy up now this guy is very very
prolific and he doesn't have like one
specialty genre he goes all over the
place he directed uh 20 000 leagues
under the sea the original fantastic
voyage tora toratora soylent green
uh coney and the destroyer
red sonja yeah uh he's done musicals
he's done west he's done everything i
want to get redstone you haven't seen it
since i was a kid but i haven't either
it's expensive
is it yeah for the blu-ray it's
expensive i guess it's a limited
production yeah maybe that's got arnold
did it i know it does yeah
but um people say it sucks but
i haven't seen i've seen it maybe once
or twice when i was a kid when it came
out really yeah yeah but yeah so i saw
this a bunch of times when i was growing
up but i always really liked it it was
one of those movies that whenever i was
like flipping through the channels and i
saw that it was on cinemax or whatever
i'd be like ooh and like i just sit
there and watch it again because i was
like 13. what do i know but um so i
always kind of had a soft spot for this
one
i think i like it because
it seems like
it's sort of trying to replicate the
tone of the first one
it's like because you said when it first
started like before it kind of goes like
crazy toward the end like the special
effects aren't great you can tell they
didn't spend a lot of money on that they
weren't that bad for the time though but
they weren't that bad for the time so
there is like some cheesy [ __ ] in there
but it's fine i've seen worse
um but you said well this is actually
like a serious
horror movie like there it's not zany or
goofy or nothing like that there is like
an actual
they are trying to like take it
seriously it is kind of like slow burn
and creepy and [ __ ] like they go through
a paranormal error
angle and they got a pair of
psychologists on there and some of the
[ __ ] that they say it's kind of based on
parapsychology you know kind of and [ __ ]
happens in the movie so it's not a bad
movie yeah it's just it's not a really
good edit i'll re-edit this
i kind of feel like um yeah there was
maybe toward the end because honestly i
liked the build up of it i know that a
lot of people that don't like this movie
think that it's like oh it's really slow
or it's boring or it's just like people
talking but honestly i did i didn't mind
that um i kind of because the original
amityville horror was kind of like that
too
um so i kind of liked that sort of more
low-key yeah kind of [ __ ] and then i
just think that because you had that and
i was like rolling with that but then
like toward the end it gets like a
little bit goofy it it tries to almost
be the the george c scott movie remember
that haunted house movie that he was in
the changeling it's kind of like it's
trying to be that serious it doesn't
really achieve it
but it's it's trying to get gravitas
like that if you ask me yeah or
it ends up being
looking kind of like house house one but
not as no comedy though but it kind of
reminded me of a house visually
ellie well it did toward the end yeah
but
yeah but i mean that was kind of pain
well i mean i don't know this one didn't
have like as much comedy because house
was actually sold as like a horror
comedy it's a comedy i'm just talking
about the visual tone of it yeah
it was kind of like the quality was
similar didn't have as many costumes but
those costumes weren't great either but
they're just
house was great though because you
weren't supposed to take that one
seriously it was just a fun adventure
kind of like you know evil dead i think
is what they were ripping off
well yeah house yeah because that was
like so successful it was a me i think
it was a mainstream evil dead kind of
tones down for a wider audience yeah i
remember saying in the day evil dead was
[ __ ] cutting edge you weren't flippy
watching that [ __ ]
they played that over and over again
over over and over at the [ __ ]
drive in where me and graham used to
[ __ ] take our dates
back in high school
and they did they played evil dead
[ __ ] once every couple weekends yeah
i mean how can you not live evil dead
late show yeah cars would be bouncing in
the back man
it was just mobile hotel mobile motel
you guys missed it you youngsters you
missed it
the driving was the [ __ ] well driving
was the [ __ ]
you
okay you could party you could do
anything and drive it they didn't care
hugo said i love house yeah i do too and
then oracle said i even have a soft spot
for house the second story i do too um i
watched it again more recently and i was
like this is like barely even a horror
movie but
there's just it's so weird
and it's just like so i don't know and
like i said i saw it like a million
times when i was growing up and i was
like oh my god they were on all the
drugs like whoever wrote this because
it's like it has but i was like there's
still something kind of like nostalgic
and fun about it and i have the same
thing with this movie just this is one
of those ones this one house
um time after time like all those kind
of movies that i saw like right around
this time period when i was like 12 or
13 years old and i saw him like multiple
times because they were always on
because you know hbo cinemax stuff like
that they hadn't been around like a huge
amount of time so they didn't have this
vast catalog like nowadays so a lot of
times like one month they'd show like
the same like three movies like all day
or like you know so you'd see like the
same ones over and over
and this is one that i saw a lot so yeah
this has tony roberts in it who
he was in a lot of woody allen movies
actually he was in annie hall he was in
like a [ __ ] ton of those
guy from smart yeah yeah that's a
different that's a different guy though
but yeah i mean he was in
tony roberts has done other stuff too
but that's like what he's best known for
for being in a [ __ ] ton of uh woody
allen movies this had tess harper in it
who was in tender mercies she was in
crimes of the heart she was spent more
recently she was in no country for old
men she's on breaking bad which i think
somebody brought up earlier
uh robert joy who i immediately
recognized from desperately seeking
susan
he was also in csi new york he was a
land of the dead the remake of hills
have eyes uh you had candy clark who was
in american graffiti she was a man who
fell to earth
uh cat's eye the remake of the blob
zodiac
and uh this hat also had uh somebody
pointed out aunt becky from full house
uh lori laughlin
uh she was in this and i think this was
her screen debut also
wasn't she the one that got into that
scandal where she like paid to have her
daughter like in put into college or
something i have no idea i don't
remember now well no but i mean i
thought there was like some kind of
scandal and like she did like a short
amount of prison time for it but i can't
remember what it was yeah maybe back
then it would die no i'm saying that was
like fairly recently i think that was
fairly recently i don't know all the
details but i just remember like saying
and i will say too that when i was
looking up her wikipedia page because i
know what she looks like i remember see
like from phil full house and everything
but i on her wikipedia page i don't know
who is controlling her wikipedia page
but the main picture you know when they
have a celebrity in the main picture
they have up there of them the one they
put up up there for her i would be very
bad if i was her because i was like she
looks like a homeless crazy person but
she might be in this picture well she's
not because i've seen other pictures of
her recently and i was just like who the
[ __ ] put that crazy ass picture it
looked like some weird and it was like
super low quality too so i was like
maybe somebody that hates her is like up
there like trolling her wikipedia page a
lot of people that you grew up with see
and turned out to be crazy homeless
people
from hollywood movies you know the girl
from
from friday 13th part one the one that
was making out with kevin bacon got
stabbed through the through the uh
yeah yeah that chick ended up being a
crazy homeless person
yeah i mean i'm sure it's not widespread
obviously but it does happen no it
happens yeah you know
well they were on the edge when they
hire
you know yeah
but yeah so this is basically
you know i don't know if it was star
studded cast but everybody in it is
somebody you would recognize
so like i said there was a lawsuit so
they're like okay the lutz has
complained so we can't have anything to
do with that so this one does actually
it is sort of based on something that
really happened like i said the main guy
is based on stephen kaplan who went
there to like
debunk the um the amityville house the
lutz story so it's loosely based on his
thing but then it kind of does its own
thing but this one
is kind of like
i don't know if i'd necessarily called a
sequel to the first one because the
second one was kind of like a prequel
but not because it's supposedly about
the defeo family but they couldn't call
them that whereas this one
meg ryan's character does actually refer
to
the real case does refer to ronnie defeo
came in here and did this that the other
thing so this is going back to like the
real
story so it's almost like this is like a
sequel to the first one rather than a
sequel to the second one you know what
i'm saying so yeah so what you have is
you have this journalist
who
well he's the journalist and candy clark
plays the photographer right so their
whole shtick at the beginning the very
beginning is like a seance and you think
that they're like a husband and wife and
they're like oh i'm here to contact my
dead kid ricky or whoever and she has
this like old medium and this other guy
and they're running this whole uh seance
and then it turns out that these two
candy clark and tony roberts are
actually like debunking uh this medium
so they like take pictures and they have
like this guy walking around with like
this glowing [ __ ] like on a [ __ ]
fishing line and all this other [ __ ]
so then it turns out that after they've
done this all all of this uh stuff where
they're debunking the seance
they um run into
the uh guy that owns the house and he's
like pissing and moaning about
oh well i haven't been able to sell it
because of the birders and like
everybody's freaked out about it and
like they don't mention the lutz family
obviously because they weren't allowed
to but they kind of imply that
everyone's like afraid of this house
because it's like infamous not just
because of the murders but maybe there's
some other paranormal [ __ ] going on so
the realtor is like oh well i can't sell
it and tony roberts who is going through
kind of a little bit of an acrimonious
divorce with his wife uh tess harper uh
is like hey it has so happens that i'm
looking for a place to live and uh if
this place is going cheap i'll buy it uh
because he's a skeptic and he doesn't
believe that it's haunted and he doesn't
give a [ __ ] that like people got
murdered in there so he ends up buying
it
and uh then obviously haunting ensues
and so then his daughter like laurie
laughlin plays his teenage daughter and
she like gets involved in it and all
this other kind of stuff like the mom
doesn't want her staying there she's
like afraid of the house and meg ryan
makes her go over there and have like
another like ouija board kind of thing
and they bring some [ __ ] up yeah so
there's like the well to hell in the
basement
there's all that kind of stuff going on
but like i said and and then toward the
end they bring in uh robert joy's
character who's like a parapsychologist
i guess i think he's a parapsychologist
or some kind of something
and um so he brings in like a whole team
and they're doing an investigation and
that's kind of when everything goes off
like demon [ __ ] comes like out of the
well
with the frozen whatever that was it was
supposed to be frozen right that like
thing that came out of the thing i guess
it was look at a bunch of ice crystals
i guess that's what it was well yeah
because when candy clark was in there at
one point like all of the like freezing
[ __ ] came out of the like the wind the
freezing wind came out of the thing out
of the basement and like got her cold
and everything and then she flipped out
and uh yeah so this is a 3d movie
but i was actually surprised by how
yeah there's a few scenes where it's
like hey throwing a frisbee at you or
hey there's like a car accident where
like a pipe comes through the you know
windshield that comes out she's stuck
but it's not
super egregious i mean it just happens
like a couple of times
um
so i'm glad they kind of like restrained
themselves a little bit with that i
could have done without the stuff with
the flies because the flies look
terrible
fake well i guess they must have been 3d
so it probably looked they thought it
looked real cool 3d i mean it might have
looked good in 3d i'm not sure but
obviously i can't watch it in 3d now
or whatever they were they almost look
like cg like old cgi but i don't think
they had the or they either that or they
had like they just drew one like on a on
a little cell and like just moved it
around all the feathers some of some of
the
stuff that some of it was just some of
those rubber toy flies with the clear
wings these to sell yeah on the end of a
fishing line yeah that's what some a lot
of it was i think that's maybe what it
was yeah but i said you know other than
that like
like i said a lot of the first part of
the movie where they're kind of
establishing like the skeptic guy and
he's like oh there's nothing going on in
here what are you talking about but they
have like um
you know candy clark's character who
kind of believes in it like she goes to
the house and she had taken some
pictures of the realtor guy and just
like in the omen
when she develops the pictures like his
face is all [ __ ] up but like nothing
else in the
in the picture is [ __ ] up so she like
tells her
friend or her colleague like look at
this and this weird he's like yeah
that's weird but whatever it's probably
like a coincidence but then like the
real the realtor like dies and the he
goes up and gets attacked by flies and
he has a heart attack or a stroke or
whatever and so he dies in there and
she's like yeah it's not weird that i
took a picture and he's like no that's
not weird at all so like so then she
goes to the house
and there's actually like i said they
have a good job they did a good job of
like just her creeping around the house
and it's like kind of spooky and
it's kind of a slow burn type of thing
she gets killed later too in like a
really horrible way but she gets like
burned alive in the car right yeah yeah
and then like well yeah and like her
body like
well because they wanted to do the thing
like the 3d thing like
the the burn body like popping out
actually but honestly that burned body
but that was some good that was a good
effect i thought they're pretty good i
just kind of feel like
they should have i think they should
have like kept it a little bit more
restrained throughout the end i could
have done without
the demon
monster like popping out of the hell
hole
people would just would have said it was
boring which is what they did slow and
boring that's right well people said it
was boring anyway you said so i mean you
know it's not boring it's just kind of
slow the edit isn't right i think i'd
speed the edit up a little bit in
certain areas but the story's pretty
good
so it's okay yeah i mean i think it was
a good angle because you know the first
one is dealing with
hey here's this family that moves into
this house where a multiple murder
happened and then you know ghosts and
then the second one is kind of dealing
oh here's the thing with the multiple
murder except also ghosts that maybe
caused the multiple murder and then this
one takes like the skeptical
parapsychological angle like a skeptical
guy moves in there and he's like there's
nothing happening in here what the [ __ ]
and so i like that they kind of like
went a different way with it because
they could have just done like the same
thing three times and they didn't so i
like that they actually went like a
slightly different way with it i liked
the
[ __ ] toward the end where which was
almost kind of a little bit like
poltergeist now that i'm thinking about
it but where the pair of psychologists
came and like with the whole team and
they set up all around the house they
had all the monitors and microphones and
stuff like that i feel like that part of
it could have gone on a little bit
longer
you know what i'm saying because i feel
like
all this stuff happens you know
um you know the paranormal [ __ ] like
ramps up
and
then you know the parapsychologist comes
in there and he's like okay well i'm
gonna set this up but then it's pretty
much they set up like literally like two
minutes later
just all hell breaks loose
and then it's the end you know what i
mean yeah so i kind of feel like that
that could have been like
built that part up a little bit more
like maybe you could have brought up
i mean can we spoil it i guess it's 83
yeah
um because the the teenage daughter
dies yeah and actually i really liked
and this was the i don't know why this
scene like
out of this whole movie like this is the
scene that i remembered but the scene
like after she because her she goes out
with her friends in the boat like uh on
the lake where the house is
and she drowns
and um so they bring her body back but
meanwhile her mom is at the house and
she doesn't know that her daughter has
drowned and she sees her daughter like
walking and she's all wet but she's
dressed and everything and just walking
past her like up the steps and she just
turns real slow and like looks at her
ghost and she's like susan what are you
doing and then she just like kind of
smiles at her and then just walks and
she won't answer and it's for some
reason i just always thought that was so
so creepy yeah like because
she doesn't look like a ghost she just
looks like a regular ass person but the
way she acts like always like creeped me
out so for some reason that's like the
main scene that i remembered from this
was just her turning around really
slowly and her hair's all wet and then
she's just like smiles and just like
keeps walking up the stairs i was like
ooh
that made an impression on you because
it didn't really make an impression on
me yeah well i mean like i said i saw
this a million times but that was um for
some reason that just it's always like
weird things like that that like creep
me out and it's usually not something
that's like real overtly creepy it's
just something like that that will stick
in my mind you know what i mean i think
it's the subtlety that's like creepier
to me
just because it seems more realistic
like what if you were in a house and
like you so and your daughter
unbeknownst to you was dead and like you
saw her walking through the house and
she was all wet and she wouldn't like
talk to you and she was acting really
weird i just think that would be really
creepy well there's a lot of stories
like that yeah that's what i'm saying so
i think that maybe that's why that made
an impression but i really liked that so
they could have i feel like they could
have maybe i don't know they could have
maybe
moved the daughter's death like up a
little bit because it's actually like
the daughter's death
that sort of triggers the
parapsychologist to come in there and do
the investigation
because the mom
is like flipping out and she's like no
susan's still alive like i saw her in
the house and she's like losing her [ __ ]
and so she wants to stay in the house
and she's like acting crazy and so the
dad is like okay well maybe if we have
you guys in here
and we show her that there's nothing
going on in the house like maybe she'll
get over it and actually like accept
that her daughter's dead so that's why
they bring the team in but i feel like
there's just the team wasn't in there
for long enough it's like they just got
there they set everything up and then
like literally like a minute later like
crazy [ __ ] starts happening yeah like
you know it's a grand finale they kind
of went the way yeah
yeah you know they're trying to go out
with a bag
and i get that i get that i just wish
there had been because it seemed like it
was it seemed like this nice kind of
like slow progression which i was
digging and then it's just like wow and
then it ended there was a lot there was
a lot of um prom there was a lot of
parallels with uh poltergeist hmm
because they held up and omen too as
well well at the end i'm talking about
because they helped hold out promise
that they might be able to bring her
back to life through that portal to hell
right and a demon comes through it kind
of like in the portal to poltergeist but
they never get her out of there
yeah because it's almost kind of like
now did we establish or did the movie
establish
that that green thing
that or the purple thing or whatever the
glowing whatever orb
that the mom was following was that
actually susan's ghost or was that the
demon pretending to be susan's ghost to
lure them down to the well i could tell
you
i was under the impression that it
wasn't actually i thought it was like
the demon making itself look like her
maybe because that's what demons do it
was unclear
they were probably pulling it out of
their ass
yeah but i'm just i don't know i'm
saying i i didn't think that that was
really her ghost it seemed kind of like
the ending was rushed
that's what it seemed like yeah that's
the only thing i kind of just wish they
had prolonged like with the team there i
think they were like look this shit's
going on too long we gotta end this
ended now it's gonna be a big bang and
then we can [ __ ] wrap this shoot up
yeah because man the house falls apart
and blows up and right and it goes oh
they'll love it the kids will love it
that's a wrap you know and doesn't like
the parapsychologist gets like pulled
down into the yeah into the well and
yeah kind of like out of um a couple
other ghost movies where somebody gets
pulled down into [ __ ] holes in the
ground like the one with that haunted
that haunted
um they called it a hotel but i think it
was a resort
what was the name of that one where they
had the ghost of the good guy trying to
help him never and it was built it was
containing the the soul of the devil
down there uh
that's where the dog came running it
sounded like a damn tie fighter from
[ __ ] star wars and they used [ __ ]
tie fighter oh yeah what's the name of
that what the [ __ ] was the name of that
oh
i liked it i can't remember
yeah
house is coming to live and
electrocuting people
but that's the thing it's like well
because if you think about poltergeist
for example which like i said it seemed
like it did influence this
but the evil
oh yeah there you go it was called the
evil that's right we were yeah we
reviewed that a while back that it has
like four different channels it is a
good movie yeah it has like four
different titles but the most common one
is the evil i recommend it is a good
movie i thought it was good
danny rolling ghostface said it would be
more scary if her ghost was actually the
demon see i think her ghost was actually
the demon yeah i thought that the demon
was just using the image of her or the
and her voice and stuff
like to [ __ ] with the living people i
thought and to like lure them down to
the basement that's what i that's the
impression i got i don't know if they
like clearly said that or anything but
i'm pretty sure that's why but yeah if
you think about poltergeist when the
investigative team got there it was like
a long thing it was like they were there
for a couple days and like they built up
you know it's like the you know the
little lights flashed and they were you
know but then like as it went on like
crazy or [ __ ] start to happen like the
dude like pulls his own face off and
[ __ ] like that you can you can do that
you can do like over-the-top [ __ ]
because poltergeist did it like i said
with the steak crawling across the
the counter and like him tearing his
face off and whatnot but
i just feel like i don't know like i
feel like the tone of this they could
have i wish they would have restrained
the end a little bit like i said i
didn't need to see the demon or it
didn't need to look like that you could
have done it more like subtly i guess
and
i just wish that end part with the
with this parapsychologist being there
would have gone on a little bit longer
with them when they got there like
little [ __ ] started happening that was
still like plausible deniability
but it wasn't like that like they just
got there they set up and then all of a
sudden oh there's this big [ __ ]
purple orb
you know and
and they go down there and then the
house starts falling apart and like the
parapsychologist gets his face burned
off and [ __ ] like that so i just feel
like they could have built it up a
little bit more so maybe the movie
needed to be a little bit longer
in that section and maybe a little bit
shorter in other sections but overall i
actually have a lot of affection for
this movie i guess because i saw it a
lot when i was a teenager um and it kind
of like i said it kind of stuck with me
i remembered this one more than the
second one
i think
i think i saw this one a lot more times
than the second one because i'd seen the
second one before but
you know i think the second one's a
classier movie
see now i think the second one is much
sleazier really
production wise yeah maybe lighter
it's just tighter to me but i don't know
it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter they're
they're probably just about the same the
the difference between them is just
going to be taste
they try to get some gravitas with this
one like like it's a serious movie it
kind of is yeah it kind of is just the
ending kind of blows it a little bit the
tone is not right for the red foot for
the rest of the movie and it was i
thought it was kind of slow in places i
would have re-edited it but the work on
the movie is pretty good yeah i mean i i
thought it was pretty good and honestly
it
when it came out like it debuted uh at
the theater at like at number one but
then after that it just kind of went
downhill and it ended up being like a
financial failure
um and i think it only has like 10 on
rotten tomatoes but
i don't know i mean they got people that
i like they got people that like
exorcist two with richard burton and he
takes all kinds and he's
he's drunk as [ __ ] through the whole
thing i could tell he's drunk
but he sounds british though he sounds
real british
uh sly asks are there people living in
the house today i believe there are
but a loss doesn't look like that it
doesn't look like that anymore yeah a
long time ago they had it renovated so
it didn't have those iconic it also does
windows doesn't have the same address
anymore they changed the ads yeah they
changed the address too because they
were sick of everybody coming but i mean
you know i'm sure you could find it on
the internet if you probably know it's
not even there but it doesn't look like
it used to look yeah i thought i heard
they moved it but maybe i don't know if
they actually moved the house or if they
just changed the address
but i know for sure that it doesn't have
those windows anymore because they were
sick of everybody coming by and sitting
in their yard and taking pictures and
[ __ ]
so
you know there's that but i'm pretty
sure like somebody does live in there
but that's the thing like people that lo
that moved into it after the lutz's
moved out nobody ever
complained that the [ __ ] was haunted
you know what i'm saying
it's not like well i kind of feel like
that happens with a lot of kind of real
big
uh
iconic like paranormal cases where he's
like oh my god this house was so [ __ ]
haunted and we ran out of there after a
month or whatever and then like people
move in there after they're like it's
fine there's there's nothing going on
it's maybe it's just geraldo went up
there and did a show i think one time
remember that did he really oh yeah
that's a good live show in there i think
that's right and probably [ __ ]
[ __ ] all happened it was a young
geraldo
yeah it was [ __ ] i always kind of
wondered if he should probably
if i remember i wonder what he ever
stooped to like get production
assistance to like go in there like
knock on the walls or something like
that so it looked like something was
happening y'all can correct me y'all can
correct me it was a long time i think it
was i think it was the amityville house
it might have been one of the other ones
well i remember the only the main one i
remember him doing was that was that
vault yeah right who's
al capone's vault when they opened it it
was like nothing in there yeah some
bottles they were drinking and [ __ ]
through the bottles in there put the
dirt in there and made the wall
after all
yeah i don't even know if he did
he's like from now on we'll actually
open the ship beforehand to see if we
actually have a show before we do all
this [ __ ] hype about it i remember
correctly he gets into the uh he gets
into the amityville house and they walk
around it i think they did a little
seance and interviewed a few people and
it was it was it was a bust but i
imagine a lot of people [ __ ] watched
it
well that's really all they care about i
mean they don't care if they don't find
anything it's all like they just wanted
to get eyeballs on the [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm
pretty sure it was the amityville house
i'm not
so now i was kind of thinking about this
when i was watching the movie last night
though is that the guy that's the
skeptic in the movie
and they're like well you know obviously
like people actually really did get
killed in that house and i was thinking
to myself
would i be okay
with buying a house and living in a
house that that had happened
and i can honestly say that i would
probably be all right with it
i wouldn't i think the only thing that
would bother me is just people coming
like lookie-loos like people coming by
and going ooh it's the murder house and
you'd have to like shoot people off your
[ __ ] lawn all the time no i couldn't
live in a house that like five six
people got killed in you couldn't no
it's just a house it's not that yeah
it's not the houses yeah i'm not a
normal dude i come in and wake that [ __ ]
up
[Laughter]
i always thought it's not the house's
fault it's the person's fault and if the
person is gone then the house is
probably fine i always feel bad for the
house the house is just like [ __ ] i
didn't
i didn't cause this that rspk and
activate all that [ __ ]
well yeah you probably haven't or that
[ __ ] i don't think subconscious would
would believe i was activating it it
would just and then it would do all
kinds of weird [ __ ] it would bother me
maybe that's what it is maybe it's not
just that it's not the house it's
somebody moving in there and worrying
about causes it and that's gonna cause
yeah it's like a fake ghost yeah because
i kind of feel like if i moved in there
but like i said that's it i i genuinely
do not believe it's the house as well
that recurrent spontaneous psychokinesis
let's go rspk
yeah
and you know people say well that
doesn't exist man go watch that lex
friedman they got guys some scientists
on there that are coming up saying now
well basically could be that reality is
an illusion that really it's all
consciousness
that consciousness dictates what's real
and you know
that was a good show i already gave the
guy's name on another show i forgot what
it was yeah you did i was listening to
that [ __ ] and i was like yeah it sounds
like something
something out of a poltergeist event
oracle said i'd be tempted to have my
stepmom visit she's a priest although
priests don't uh fare so well in
amityville movies
in most case priests show up and it gets
worse get out yeah well yeah that seems
to happen on like every episode of
haunting too because i'm like don't call
it priest don't call a priest it always
gets worse after you call the priest or
sometimes like you call the priests and
they're like oh and then it was better
for a week and then it came back like 10
times worse i was like that's what you
don't call the priest there's no reason
to do a history of this house i know the
guy that built it people there's a bunch
of people that used to live here they
were all related
there's always like nine cars out in the
[ __ ] front of the garage well this
house isn't that old
either they're they're gone though now
yeah it was a rental
this house was a rental yeah because the
same people that
the same people owned it that owned the
house we lived in in sanford they own a
bunch of houses
um
you know they're a couple they just have
like a bunch of real estate and they
rent them out so all right um look what
about you but i'm hungry yeah that means
we've been going uh 43 minutes oh yeah
we're good i'm gonna start cooking for
you want some ramen yeah i want some
ramen with some eggs and veggies in it
okay yeah yeah so uh so yeah so have a
good uh rest of your day today everybody
and remember tomorrow is wednesday so
tomorrow is our big main show we're
going to be talking about lewis carroll
and alice liddell uh so that should
probably be creepy that's creepers
yeah well yeah we'll see like i said
it's an interesting discussion to have
because i'm always interested in like
the cultural differences between
modern day and
victorian kind of uh attitudes and i
kind of want to get into that a little
bit too but yeah so come by for that
that'll be super fun uh and we will see
you guys again tomorrow
bye